said a fear of seeming Politically
Incorrect a fear of saying the wrong
thing and I mean look let's firstly
address the fact that this is becoming a
real problem today people can't say what
they really think because they don't
want to get cancelled or you know in
some cases they don't want to lose their
job for saying the wrong thing and it's
happening I mean here in the UK they're
about to pass the Online safety bill
which is essentially a law it's waiting
on the Royal Ascent but it I can see it
happening in the next sort of month or
so it's essentially a law that limits
freedom of speech so we are literally
living in a time where you can't say
what you really think you can only say
what you think so far as it agrees with
the general status quo of society so so
long as it agrees with what the
government deems acceptable opinions or
not